so I just basically produced more
stomach acid than the average person
it's easily cured by the way you just
take you've seen the commercials for
product or like 24 hour next to you yeah
that I can take one pill every day and
it goes away but I'm not medicated
because they're in covet it's really
nice when people get a little too close
Carlos Mencia he's been on Showtime HBO
of course he had his hit show from the
mind of Mencia on Comedy Central and he
will be at the south point this weekend
and he's with us right now it's Carlos
Mencia hey look I look thinner
look at me I look good okay what's this
you're wearing here Dodgers you're a
Dodgers fan I'm a Dodger fan so I lost
the bet with my mind and they're huge
huge fans with Astros and I had to so
the BET was this I had to put on an
astro hat and yell out as loud as I
could that they're Champions he never
said where so I waited on the way here I
was like my wife said what are you gonna
do I said there's an exit called zizzix
on the way there I have no idea what's
there but it looks empty I'm gonna pull
over there and in front of nobody I'm
just gonna record it and put it out and
it's out there what I did it do not ever
exit zizzix if you want to know what
crazy people do when they get way too
drunk and way too crazy and way too high
and way too that that's the exit they go
to to do the crazy stuff bro everything
on the floor this is a drone I threw my
shoes away I literally threw my shoes
away because I was stepping on things
that I was like what are you people
doing here listen how many times have
you done that drive to La back and forth
I can't encounter I've never I've never
stopped on this world I don't even know
if that's how you pronounce it you do
that right
exactly when you're in Las Vegas yeah
South Point you gamble
I don't anymore I used to yeah but the
amount of money that it takes for me to
get to tingle is way too much yeah
because if I win it's not that big of a
deal but if I lose I feel so horrible so
if I do gamble I'll like do the go go
find a five dollar table somewhere and
just have fun a little bit but you know
what I mean but that feeling is amazing
when you win oh bro
that feeling of oh my God if I lose this
I lose everything but if I win
[Laughter]
no matter what good or bad starts with I
was up yeah oh yeah when you're up
whether it be five dollars 500 as soon
as you're up you walk yeah then you walk
but that's this that's this town are you
into horseback riding yes all right
because there's a big equestrian event
over at the south point this weekend so
I'm visiting the equestrian writers and
the Carlos Mencia fans there he's
wearing those writing boots yes which is
like I did not know was was uh sexy I
don't know if that's appropriate to say
or not but a lot and some of the guys
wear them too yeah yeah
did not realize that I can find the man
attractive and not want to be with him
but go let's just have dinner
Thanksgiving a week away from
Thanksgiving you got two boys what are
you doing for Thanksgiving you do you
cook a big turkey huge turkey so I'm
gonna miss cause I'm not gonna be with
my family you're going to be my wife's
family Portuguese and uh German so I'm
gonna miss my rice my beans my tamales
go on uh all of that but we're gonna get
this purple cabbage that they make this
uh soup that they make that's different
they put Kraut on certain things that I
love so I'm gonna get to I'm gonna be
for the first time the American that
gets to go what is this that you guys
are making what is this why does it
smell funny water what's that purple
stuff what is that
but because I cause all the time yeah
hey what what's this green stuff in the
beans it's called cilantro seriously
it's not that big a deal so I get to be
on the other side of it I love the cars
like we got to wrap up thank you so much
we're looking forward to seeing at the
south point this weekend you're always
welcome on the show man I just touched
your leg right there
look at the whitest Brown Look at that I
am so man I'm so I'm whiter than you I'm
Fernandez
this weekend Carlos Mencia uh show start
tonight Saturday and Sunday Rocky will
send it over to you